SOCIALISM CAUSES POVERTY, CAN BE
EVIL, IT HAS NEVER WORKED, IT
NEVER WILL WORK.
THERE WAS A REACTION IS THE
RELATABLE PODCAST HOST, ALLIE
BETH STUCKEY, THE HOST OF
"AMERICA FIRST" ON THE SALE OF
RADIO NETWORK, DR. SEBASTIAN
GORKA.
DR. GORKA, YOU KNOW FIRSTHAND AS
A WORLD TRAVELER, SOCIALISM ONE
TRIED HAS FAILED.
OBAMA TRIED, HE WANTED TO
REDISTRIBUTE THE WEALTH.
HIS POLICIES, STIFLING
REGULATION, HIGH TAXES,
REDISTRIBUTION, 13 MILLION MORE
AMERICANS ON FOOD STAMPS,
8 MILLION MORE AND PROPERTY.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
>> SEAN, MY PARENTS CRAWLED
ACROSS A MINEFIELD TO ESCAPE THE
KIND OF SYSTEM THAT
OCASIO-CORTEZ WISHES TO CREATE
IN AMERICA.
I THINK IT IS VERY TELLING THAT
SHE HAS THESE LATENT
TOTALITARIAN TENDENCIES WHEREBY
SHE THINKS THE PEOPLE'S WILL IN
VENEZUELA SHOULD BE IGNORED, AND
MADURO'S REGIME SHOULD BE
RECOGNIZED.
CAN YOU IMAGINE, SEAN, IN THE
LAST SIX DAYS, THE MEDIA HAD
PAID AS MUCH ATTENTION TO
VENEZUELA AS THEY DID TO THE
FAKE NEWS ABOUT THE CATHOLIC
COVINGTON SCHOOLBOYS?
BEING
RACIST?
IF THAT ACTUALLY TOLD THE TRUTH
ABOUT VENEZUELA, NOBODY IN
AMERICA WOULD WISH WITH THIS
WOMAN WISHES TO PUT UPON US.
40 COUNTRIES HAVE TRIED THIS
COUNTRY, AND IT HAS ALL FAILED.
REDISTRIBUTION OF WEALTH MEANS
YOU HAVE TO TAKE IT FROM
SOMEBODY ELSE FIRST.
SOCIALISM IS INHERENTLY
DICTATORIAL, AND THIS WOMAN,
OCASIO-CORTEZ, WISHES TO SEE
THAT IN AMERICA.
>> Sean: IT IS ALL THE
DEMOCRATS NOW.
IT IS OCASIO-CORTEZ, IT IS
CONRAD de BLASIO.
EVERYONE THAT ASPIRES TO BE
PRESIDENT, THEY WANT TO TAKE
THIS DIRECTION.
THE PROMISE THAT WAS CLOSEST TO
NATIONALIZE HEALTH CARE WAS KEEP
YOUR DACA, PAY LESS.
PEOPLE SAW THE PREMIUMS GO UP AS
MUCH AS 200% OR MORE.
MILLIONS LOST THEIR DOCTORS,
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ONLY HAVE
ONE CHOICE, MANY, MANY TOWNS AND
COUNTIES IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> RIGHT.
IT HASN'T WORKED HERE, AND IT
HASN'T WORKED ANYWHERE ELSE, AND
YET WE KEEP ON SEEING THESE
RECYCLED IDEA FROM PEOPLE LIKE
BERNIE SANDERS AND
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
LIKE YOU SAID, THEY USED TO BE
ON THE FRINGES, WE WOULD LAUGH
AT SOMEONE LIKE SANDERS OR LAUGH
AT 829-YEAR-OLD WHO REALLY DOES
NOTHING ABOUT POLITICS, BUT WHEN
YOU SEE SOMEONE LIKE
NANCY PELOSI OR MAINSTREAM
DEMOCRATS ACQUIESCE TO PEOPLE
LIKE HER, IT REALLY STARTS TO
WORRY WHEN THE MAJORITY OF THE
COUNTRY SEEMS TO BE LEANING THAT
DIRECTION.
SPECIFICALLY MILLENNIALS, WHICH
IS SOON TO BE THE BIGGEST
GENERATION EVER IN OUR NATION.
NANCY PELOSI UNDERSTANDS THAT
SHE HAS TO ACQUIESCE TO THE FAR
LEFT RADICAL OPEN BORDERS,
DEMOCRATS, BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING TO PEOPLE LIKE
OCASIO-CORTEZ AND BERNIE SANDERS
AS THE FUTURE OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> Sean: ELIZABETH WARREN.
THE THING IS, I GUESS IT IS
APPEALING -- LOOK, EVERYONE, AND
I'VE SPENT A PART OF MY ADULT
LIFE, INDEPENDENT FINANCE
LICENSE 18.
THE COLLEGE I WENT TO, I PAID
FOR MYSELF.
I WORKED FULL-TIME WHILE DOING
IT.
LIVE PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK FOR
MANY YEARS OF MY 20s, AND IT
IS APPEALING MAYBE TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE BECAUSE IT WOULD TAKE
AWAY FEAR, THE GOVERNMENT IS
GOING TO PROVIDE DAY CARE,
HEALTH CARE, HOUSING, A NEW CAR
MAY BE THE NEXT PROPOSAL.
DR. GORKA, BUT DON'T WORRY,
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE IT FROM
THOSE PEOPLE.
IT IS REALLY ABOUT THEM KEEPING
POWER, IT IS A POWER PLAY, AND
IT WAS     WILL ALWAYS DISAPPOIN
IT WAS     WILL ALWAYS DISAPPOI.
>> IT IS ONLY APPEALING IF YOU
HAVE NO SENSE OF HISTORY AND THE
SUFFERING OF MILLIONS OF PEOPLE,
100 MILLION KILLED AND OTHERS
PERSECUTED, THAT IS THE REALITY.
IT IS NICE AND THE WAY OF PEOPLE
GIVING YOU SOMETHING FOR
NOTHING, WHICH NEVER ACTUALLY
HAPPENS IN REAL LIFE.
THAT IS THE SHAME OF IT.
THE RADICALS HAVE TAKEN OVER THE